aktuelle Anlass Liebe Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer unterbrechen wir an dieser
Stelle denn in dieser Sekunde meldet
sich der türkische Präsident Erdogan zu
Wort nach dem verheerenden Erdbeben das
in den Morgenstunden sowohl die Türkei
als auch den Norden Syriens erschüttert
hat mit im Moment mindestens 630 Toten
auf beiden Seiten der Grenze hören wir
rein was Präsident Erdogan nach dieser
Katastrophe zu sagen hat
die Gouverneure haben
in ihren Städten alle Maßnahmen
getroffen
wir haben in die Region noch zehn
zusätzliche Gouverneure geschickt
die Rettungskräfte unter anderem das
türkische halb der türkische Halbmond
ist auch in der Region
wir haben alle
Institutionen die sich auskennen mit
Rettungsarbeiten sind auch in die Region
geschickt worden
Projekte der prembol gesehen
die Arbeiten finden momentan ohne
Unterbrechung statt um eben die Bürger
die davon betroffen sind von den
Erdbeben getroffen sind
zu retten wir in Ankara in der
Hauptstadt haben wir die Arbeiten
beobachten wir die Arbeiten
intensiv
unsere Minister
sind in die Städte die vom Erdbeben
betroffen sind gefahren und haben mit
koordinationsarbeiten angefangen
auch aus dem Ausland
und von anderen Städten haben wir
in die Erdbebenregion
Instrumente geschickt und sie werden
weiterhin geschickt auch die Bürger
helfen in der Region
Wetter ist kalt es ist Winter
und in Mitternacht ist das
Erdbeben passiert und wir haben
schnellstens reagiert
bis zum Zeitpunkt haben wir
912 tote über 5000 verletzte
ich
unter den Ruinen konnten wir über 2500
Menschen retten
Gebäude sind zusammengestürzt
ihr da die Rettungsarbeiten noch
weitergehen wissen wir nicht wie sich
die totenzahl und verletzten Zahl
korrigiert wird das Wichtigste ist dass
wir dieses Erdbeben nun erstmal hinter
uns haben
wichtig ist die Kommunikation
daher ist es umso wichtiger
dass sie Straßen in die
Katastrophenregion offen bleiben die
Kommunikationsmittel nicht beschäftigt
werden
und alle Rettungskräfte durch die
Institution Abfahrts koordiniert werden
andere hilfs- und Rettungsarbeiten
sind natürlich nicht zuträglich
auch aus dem Ausland
haben 45 Länder 45 Staaten
ihre Hilfe angeboten
wünsche den Familien der toten
mein Beileid und den verletzten
gute Besserung wir werden als Volk diese
katastrophentage hinter uns lassen
der Tag ist mit 85 Millionen Bürgern
eine Hand zu werden ein Körper zu werden
ich wünsche allen unseren Bürgern
gute Besserung und
Wünsche von Gott
dass unser Land nicht mehr mit solchen
Katastrophen konfrontiert wird
ja soweit also der türkische
Staatspräsident Erdogan zu den
Auswirkungen den verheerenden Folgen
dieser Naturkatastrophe die sich heute
in den frühen Morgenstunden in im
Südosten der Türkei aber auch im
Nordwesten Syriens ereignet hat im
Moment ist von mindestens 284 Toten und
5000 verletzten allein auf türkischer
Seite die Rede Erdogan spricht aber auch
davon dass über
2500 Menschen gerettet werden konnten im
Zuge der Rettungsmaßnahmen die seit den
frühen Morgenstunden laufen über 2000
Gebäude sind nach Lage der Dinge im
Moment eingestürzt aber das ist
sicherlich oder das sind auch nur
vorläufige Zahlen auf die der türkische
Präsident Erdogan im Moment
zurückgreifen kann denn die
Bergungsarbeiten laufen ja noch und man
wird sehen welche menschliche
die Höhe dir sich dort noch ja entfalten
wird der Leiter der syrischen des
syrischen erdbebenzentrums jedenfalls
hat heute gesagt dass sei das stärkste
Erdbeben in Syrien seit
1995 auch der syrische Staatspräsident
Pascha Allers hat hat sein Kabinett zu
einer Dringlichkeitssitzung
zusammengerufen eine Naturkatastrophe
die sich also nur knapp drei Monate vor
der nächsten Parlaments und
Präsidentschaftswahl in der Türkei
ereignet hat und möglicherweise auch den
Wahlkampf beeinflussen wird wir haben
vorhin meine Kollegin Anne Brühl in
Istanbul nach den Folgen und ja dem
aktuellen Stand der Rettungsarbeiten im
Südosten der Türkei gefragt hier
Informationen von
im Moment laufen natürlich die
Rettungsarbeiten man versucht
verzweifelt verschüttete unter den
Trümmern zu finden aber das ist eben
eine riesige Region die hier in der
Türkei betroffen ist